hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics everybody else does
mathematics
mathematics is the movement of concepts
that's what everybody else does
okay we have a good day today we're
going to have
a review of what we did in the month
okay
i'm going to start with our um
criticism of the criticizer
there was a fellow who criticized the
scientific method can you believe that
criticizing the scientific method
what arguments could he possibly have
well here it is let me uh put him on and
i think he was hi
uh we have um this ver person he said
um
that you need to test
explanations
before he said we have to test
hypothesis which are assumptions you
know and now he's gonna he's saying his
argument is you also need to test
explanations
okay so here it goes give me a second
here here goes
this fellow claims that in science in
his version of science you must test the
explanation before it can become
scientific
you have to test these explanations and
if you can't test these explanations
well then you're not doing science
okay
so he says we have to test the
explanations
what could he possibly be talking about
i mean you know um like i said he's he
talked last time the previous time he
said uh talk about
you have to test the hypothesis
a hypothesis is an assumption
you know so we make an assumption like
you might make an assumption in quantum
mechanics saying that
light is mediated by particles
okay you can make that assumption
how are you going to test that
okay
you know you can't test it
and uh test an explanation well even if
you test it all you're doing is
convincing yourself or convincing
someone else
that your theory is correct
that's what he's talking about okay and
here here's the rundown can you give me
a second here
okay
test the hypothesis is to test an
assumption we don't test assumptions we
accept them at face value
in order to understand the theory
the explanation founded upon those
assumptions
that's the explanation well you know
what are you doing uh you're you're just
trying to convince someone okay you're
uh
what are you gonna do run an experiment
or what okay
what do you want me to do to test the
explanation
especially on something that is
invisible and intangible such as the
mediator of gravity
what are you going to test you're going
to run an experiment to test you know my
magic wand here you know test what's up
here what's down here
what invisible thing is pulling what
invisible thing is pushing
intangible and invisible
i mean it doesn't make any sense to say
you're going to test the theory
theory is one that you listen to you
understand it
so
you know just to comprehend it that's it
there's no more than that in science
someone might say may have an assumption
saying god okay so the individual
introduces god and then he says my
theory is that god created the universe
okay and so he goes on and he says yeah
god moved his magic wand said voila and
there was the universe great that's a
theory that's what he believes and this
is how he visualizes the origin of the
universe okay
and so
when you look at that you say okay
that's his theory okay now you can
criticize his assumption you can
criticize his theory
but
test it how are you going to test that
god is out there i mean what experiment
do you propose
it doesn't make any sense so yeah
to test
a theory as he said all you're doing is
actually um
focusing on religion unbelief what
you're doing is you know persuading
convincing converting and recruiting
that's the elements that you're
considering when you're talking about uh
testing and explanation
and that's what the prosecutor does with
the jury he tries to convince the jurors
okay to to his side of the case
and uh it's also what a priest does you
know
what does he do he talks about to come
whatever and what is he doing he's
trying to convince the flock
that's it you know so
you know so yeah experiment uh trial and
error that's technology we don't do
experiments to test
either the hypothesis or the theory you
can run whatever experiment you want at
home no problem you know go ahead and
run your experiment do whatever you have
to stand on your head if you need to but
when you come to the um
to the conference
we want you to tell us what you learned
tell us a mechanism that we can use in
physics okay and so you say this is how
i think gravity works or this is how i
think electricity works great
and you tell your theory
and
you know people might have questions
might attack it might defend it whatever
but the issue here is the attacking and
defending the saying it's correct and
correct true or false that's belief
that's got to do with opinions
religion
uh the theory is just what it is
objectively you just try to understand
it to see what the guy has going through
his mind
that's it that's all there is
okay uh we also had the moonies this
this week okay
the moonies who are the mooneys the
muniz are people who
believe that we did not go to the moon
humans did not step on the moon
now
i essentially believe that humans went
to the moon there are some issues that i
cannot explain so if a mooney approaches
me and says well bill explain this or
explain that there are some things
i personally would i am not able to
explain okay
uh does that mean that
we should throw the baby with the wash
water away and say oh that they never
went to the moon because i can't explain
this
and that's where i draw the line you
know one thing is to say that i cannot
explain certain things that i'm staring
at
and another one is to think that because
of that
you know man did not go to the moon okay
so two different things
and we have all these people one of them
here uh
he says they can't see they can't create
the effects seen in the iss footage
using
cinematic techniques he's talking about
um
you know what i showed the other day
that the astronaut was floating in there
and so on
and he says they can create that in in
the lab they can do that in hollywood
okay watch the movie gravity which i did
by the way uh a while back okay
and the mini uh
and the mini does the
i guess mini series does that explain
how the microgravity scenes were
achieved
okay
and
so i i went in there you know and here's
what i found okay
this is the astronaut on the iss okay
this is what i showed the other day and
you have this guy floating around but i
want you to see his little computer his
little uh palm top there okay he's got
it all over the place it's just floating
and this fella says that or believes
that this can be done in a lab in a uh
you know in a hollywood studio or
whatever that this is all done with
green screen okay now we can maybe
imagine this fellow being floated by
wires and doing all this a little harder
is to do what he's doing with that
little computer okay that that's what i
want you to see to show me how that's
done uh with so many so much
sophistication
here's this other uh astronaut okay and
um
and she goes in there and she releases a
drop of water big drop of water by the
way
and uh she swallows it
and uh you know how do you how do you do
that trick with uh with a
drop of water okay
uh don't tell me you don't believe it
don't tell me it's this is done in a lab
tell me um
how you do the trick even in hollywood i
mean show me show me how that's done
and what i can show you is the following
in a second here
let me uh get rid of this gal here
and here i have um how they film this
fella says go watch gravity and go watch
how they filmed it
and here are snippets of how they filmed
it how they filmed this movie gravity
the scenes that concern us here okay
here it is
give me a second
extremely long shots
these very fluid 12-minute five-minute
or three-minute long shots
it took a while to work out
tim and chevo developed this technology
in which the actors are inside a cube of
light
three main elements of the light box are
the robot moving the camera
the light box moving the lights and the
tilt rig moving the actor
okay
now that scene with the computer the
scene with the drop
first of all you can't do that
i don't think you can do that at all in
hollywood okay uh what are you gonna do
hold the drop with a little string
that's one and the other one is that
certainly
what they did with gravity did not exist
in 1969
this technology for filming was
later on discovered okay so put in the
right time frame some people are
extrapolating what they do in hollywood
today with what we the abilities we had
in 1969 which is when they went to the
moon right so you know you got to
distinguish that as well i don't think
they can do this even in hollywood today
uh so so perfectly with a little drop
floating there and all these things all
the movements of the computer
i don't think they would be able to do
that today so easily in fact uh
when you watch how they made gravity it
took them a long time just to get the
uh general scenes the easy scenes are
you know pulling someone with the
strings and moving them around that's
the easy part doing the little
things that are out there and i only saw
one scene where they have this wrench
and it's just floating very slowly in
there yeah they could have done that one
with wires but not uh i don't think they
could do this drop or anything like that
so easily okay and again that would be
today if anything
so you know i'm not convinced that um
that any of that uh the astronauts on
the iss
uh that that was filmed in hollywood no
way
but some people believe that okay and
here we have another
fellow says
look up the video called john young's
lunar salute okay it's actually one of
the very best proofs
that the moon landings were faked in a
studio with astronauts supported by
wires the sand that the astronaut kicks
up during the jump goes as high as his
foot but lands long before he does
uh-huh under gravity both sand and
astronaut would hit the ground
simultaneously okay like the famous
hammer and feather drop test okay the
astronaut is being pulled up on a wire
while the sand falls naturally according
to gravity look carefully smoking gun
well you know somebody answered him and
this is their answer okay let's go with
that first he says
uh oh sorry got the same same one
uh well the fella said sorry i got the
wrong one there anyways the fella who
answered him says you know i watched the
movie and uh
you know i didn't see anything and i
didn't see anything in here i i watched
there and i didn't see absolutely
anything here uh here's what uh you see
when you look at that movie okay you see
the
little sand falling on the
shadow
and here it starts again okay the
asteroid jumps okay
and if you look at it uh if you watch
that little movie you see an analysis of
the fact that there is dust falling
there okay and it's falling
right under his feet because they say
when you take the shot from the front
you don't see the the
particles fall and no that's not true
this fellow took the trouble of filming
this in slow motion getting a good shot
and he said the particles are there so
you know what what some of these people
believe is a smoking gun
that's that's just their belief nothing
more than that they haven't proved
anything at least you know uh certainly
that's not a smoking gun
under no circumstances so you know
again people are raising things uh just
to win an argument or because they have
strong beliefs but
they don't make their case at all
would not uh make their case in a court
of law
okay here's another fellow that luminary
in the sky talking about the iss right
it is most likely a powered mylar
helium-filled balloon
or drone it's a drone okay soaring at
roughly 32 et cetera et cetera et cetera
and again the movie interstellar and
gravity you know and they say that
that's what they're obsessed with they
think that because that was done in a
lab then or in a in a studio uh
nasa could have done in 1969 and all the
way back all that stuff also in the
studio
and first you got to distinguish the the
times you know the fact that in those
days they didn't have all the hollywood
technology to do some of these scenes or
have not had not developed them to that
level and then the other thing is that
you know um
today some of these scenes can't be done
okay that's i i think it's easier to
send a man to the moon than to do some
of these scenes that these people say oh
that was done in a studio
okay and here we have uh
this fella who i showed the other day
and he filmed
the iss from his home
okay and you can see it there i don't
think this guy is trying to fool you or
anything he's just an amateur he took a
picture
of the iss
not only did he film it with his uh
telescope he also took a picture of it
so people who deny this you know instead
of talking people should go out there
and see if they can see it with their
binoculars nasa has the route the time
when it goes through each country it
passes 15 times
a day
through a given
region and
the nasa nasa has its schedule so there
should be no reason for anyone not to
focus uh
on the iss
and locate it
and um you know if you don't have a
binocular well at least don't talk don't
say that it's not there you know first
verify that it's not there verify the
schedule verify when it goes
near your region you know that over your
house or whatever
and then go and try to see if you can
see it if you see it we're done you know
i mean this is a black or white issue
and i like the iss because see you can
you can say that man did not go to the
moon we did not go into space you can do
a lot of you can argue anything you want
what you cannot argue is that there is a
big monster orbiting the earth
now that's a smoking gun which goes
against all people who says who say that
we never went to space
because before you can put that thing up
there which was built in space by the
way over over a period of 10 years you
don't have to believe that either but
for sure to put that big monster up
there you got to tell me how they got it
up there
okay how did you get it up there
a couple rockets that took it up there
and just sent it rolling around along
and if we can do that why can't we send
a man into orbit like guardian you know
who went into orbit
i mean if we can put a thing there
that's orbiting the earth and you can
see it every 15 you know 15 times a day
every 90 minutes
well it seems like
first of all i don't know why they would
do that i mean if they're not going to
put a man in there or some people in
there to do some experiments okay so
it's just a tin can that's floating
around right no problem
that means we can send
rockets at least in low earth orbit
empty rockets right
and this was the first one that they
sent up there
i mean if this one did not exist today
if you did not see it there you would
you would say we never sent the rocket
into space even to low orbit
because there would be no way to show
you
otherwise but if we could see this
that big monster then you have to
conclude
that there were some intermediate steps
before we got to that point and that
means that
we had to have sent before we set that
monster we had to have sent um
rockets at least into low earth orbit
so if you deny that well you know i
don't know what to tell you it's just an
extreme moonie
and uh all you're just trying to do is
win an argument you can verify whether
the iss is up there okay
then the next step is to find out if
there are people inside there you know
doing experiments floating with that
thing all around the earth
which is the second level okay do can we
send a person up there that high 400
kilometers up there okay
and um
so here's uh
another father
there are other plausible explanations
for what's taken to be the iss in the
sky
okay what is it one possibility is that
the visible phenomena
phenomenon is introduced by variations
of the technology using used to generate
laser guide stars
which excite plasmas in the upper
atmosphere with ground-based laser
well if you look up uh that laser guide
stars it's used to highlight certain
patterns in the sky okay at a given
region
this person is confusing uh laser guide
stars with us you know what you see up
there you see
uh lasers that create some images up
there and they say oh see we could have
done that same thing with it with the
iss and that's absolutely not true okay
the reason
it cannot be true is that the iss goes
all around the earth every 15 minutes
you think that they're going to take the
trouble
to have a laser go all around the earth
in every country and they point that
thing up there so that anybody can pull
out their
telescope or their binoculars and see it
and would they see the lights impinging
upon it like you see there okay
so uh you know these people are just
looking for arguments to win the day
that's all there is
these are extreme moonies
all you have to do is pull out your
telescope point it at the sky and see if
the iss is there if it's there you gotta
keep your mouth shut
okay it's just that simple
okay uh here's another
file says at seven a 747 is barely
visible at 35 000. yet the iss is
visible from what altitude 400. okay 400
health
so i don't know what to tell you you
know these people just don't want to
believe that you can see this thing when
here's this fellow is filming it with a
telescope can you see the moon with a
telescope
because maybe you don't even believe
that you can see the moon with a
telescope i mean i have a pair of
binoculars i looked at the moon you know
and i don't have a telescope but i do
have a bind not a pair of binoculars and
i look at the moon i have looked at the
moon several times
and one of these days i haven't looked
at the iss yet but one of these days i'm
going to try it with the iss not because
i have doubts okay
anymore that i have doubts that i'm not
gonna
find santa claus in the north pole okay
so i don't need to go there to find out
if santa is really there
uh but the iss you know it's just uh for
curiosity to see what it looks like and
see it go around
but i have no doubts because there's so
many amateurs out there we're not
talking about nasa here we're not
talking about the european space agency
we're talking about amateurs who point
their
devices
up to the sky and they say okay i'm
gonna look for the iss according to the
schedule set by nasa or
any other
organization that's affiliated with the
program
and you should be able to see it just
don't talk if you've never tried it
don't say it can't be up there
i mean all these amateurs they're all
just
bsing
no no way i don't i don't know by that
that's why i don't need to verify the
iss that the iss is up there i'm just
saying i haven't seen it myself
but again i haven't seen santa claus and
i'm not going to verify whether he's out
there okay
okay uh here we have another one you
immediately noticed my crest ignorance
on the subject yeah
i noticed this crass ignorance and this
is what he said many people have
demonstrated beyond a shadow of a doubt
that it was impossible for 50 60s
technology to get to and from the moon
safely
i saw exactly the opposite i saw many
trips to the moon uh unmanned probes and
they reached the moon without any
problems so why would that be different
with a human in it
okay so uh when he says that many people
have demonstrated to him
okay let's make sure we understand that
he's talking about belief
okay he's not talking about the
capability we had in the 50s or 60s he
doesn't believe we had it okay
even today with 2022 technology humans
cannot go to the moon and return safely
i don't know why he says that sure we
can we can go to the moon and back uh if
we haven't gone in last 50 years there
was no need to go there there was no
need to go there in the first place okay
maybe to develop technology maybe it was
a nice experiment like saying let's be
nice let's go to the moon let's collect
some rocks see if there's anything
different over there than over here it's
that sort of thing you know there's
always money
from a big empire like the united states
to do that kind of thing or for the
russians you know they can do those
things because they have some money left
over for those kinds of projects which
help them develop military technology in
the process
and you know it's good it's good for
technology okay so that's why they do it
but then after that you know you're not
going to go to the moon every day and
put a base there not in a lab what for
what are you going to put a base on the
moon four
mining
and again you're not going to be mining
on the moon some people believe they
will but i think they're crazy because
first of all take the equipment up there
is a monster you would have to have many
trips
just to take the equipment up there then
working in those conditions i'm not sure
it's so easy
and then what are you going to collect
some rocks there and then bring them
back to earth
how much are those going to cost so
there's no way that that's gonna be
happening
ever i don't think it's ever gonna
happen
and so uh yeah
what can i say i think that
people who say that we have no
capability today they're crazy of course
we have uh we we've been sending probes
to the moon
unmanned probes for a long time we've
sent them to venus we've sent them
mercury we sent them to mars
and yeah these people are going to say
that never happened well again and is
there an iss
and if we got the iss out there
weren't there's some previous steps that
we had to take in order to get the iss
eventually up there hopefully the answer
is yes hopefully we sent many probes in
low earth orbit
um
before we sent that big monster up there
and those never happened
so you got to check the nasa program or
the
soviet uh russian uh
program and find out how many probes
they sent out there and there's a list
of them in the wikipedia
unmanned probes if you say well i don't
believe in that either which i mean you
know you're just
a flat earther who's closing his eyes
that's all you're doing okay you're just
extreme uh
moony
and it's not about extra extreme it's
about trying to show physically
how we went to the moon on the one hand
and if we did not go to the moon let's
concede that as a assumption um
how did they do the trick
show me the trick show me how the gal
swallowed that
uh
ball of water show me how the other guy
uh played around with this computer
twirling around was it held by little
threads from everywhere is that how they
did it
okay not not that kind of motion that
you saw there okay that's the issue when
you have sophisticated motion like that
that's not hollywood that's uh up there
in the iss
okay i said i do not see facts as a sign
and as not scientific like you uh-huh
for me a fact is among the things
something measurable and observable okay
i can measure the length of a cube i can
measure sunset sunrise i can observe the
isf one guy who at least observes the
iss thank you
what i measure and see are in my
definition facts
okay
so this is what he calls a fact if you
say that
uh if say if you say no that's just
belief you have to show me that
measuring the length of one side of a
cube has something to do with belief and
you can measure something totally
different
okay
and so yeah again the issue here is that
uh people like him they think that a
fact is something that again that he can
measure
and
i measure and i say and i reach a
different conclusion whatever you know
he measures the table he says it's one
meter i say no it's not
and he said measure it no i'm not going
to measure it i just don't believe you
no but it's a fact no no i don't believe
you and i don't believe i don't believe
and i don't believe and i don't believe
just like these flat earthers that
extreme moonies who say
they didn't see the iss out there you
say no but it's up there here's the
telescope look through and you'll see it
and they said no i'm not going to look
and even if they do they see well that's
a bird i mean they can say anything they
won't believe you're fact under any
circumstances you ask them the measure
they say no or if they measure they say
something else they say he measured
something else
so
you have people out there that will not
believe under any circumstance no matter
what
so fact is always your personal belief
is that's why i say in science we don't
have facts we have statements of the
fact you make a statement of what you
think is the fact it doesn't mean the
audience the entire audience the 100 of
the audience is going to accept your
fact as as a
as a truth as something that really
happened or that is okay
they might concede the assumption say
okay let's conceive this assumption okay
and see what theory is based is founded
upon it but to say that it's a fact and
it's that's it and if you don't believe
me just do it yourself you'll find out
it's a fact
uh you know i may say that i'm not gonna
do it and i may do it and say that i got
a different result and so your fact is
not my fact do we have facts for uh
space time is that a fact
is uh electron a little bead
that rolls around a proton is that a
fact
and so you know we can go on and on and
on uh what is a fact it's what you claim
to be a fact
you measure the table one meter i say i
measure one meter and one millimeter
okay so we have a different reading
which one is the fact and we can go on
and on and on there are no facts there
are only statements of the fact you can
even tell someone look the the number pi
is the
ratio between the circumference and the
diameter or whatever pythagorean
uh theorem you can you can bring
anything you want one plus one equals
two
and the other guy said it's not a fact
not for me
and you say no but it is yeah whoever
said
and what are you gonna do you're gonna
kill him he's just gonna say no no no no
so no
no facts in science science we make
statements of the fact so that people
accept it at face value and then from
their uh
proceed to understand your theory you
can found it upon it
but talking about the moon uh you know i
said that one of the reasons that they
put the
little uh seed of doubt in me
was that i heard uh armstrong you know
i'm not gonna show it again but i showed
that uh
clip
and
i thought it was a very strange reaction
from neil armstrong of course um
you know later on i saw other parts
where this guy was chasing armstrong
around to get him
to
swear on the bible
that he went to the moon and armstrong
wouldn't do it
and she said why won't you do it and
blah blah blah here's the book
and arsenal gave him the right answer he
said
i think that bible is fake
but here we have uh another individual
and he's uh he was a uh an astron alan
bean okay
and i liked his answer and he convinced
me that
i mean i want you to listen to this guy
and i think you're going to agree with
me that he's telling the truth he's he
says he went to the moon okay so he had
a little different attitude than
neil armstrong but i think you should
listen to this here goes
they're clearly pretending to be halfway
to the moon when they're not halfway to
the moon
that is
i don't care what you say
i went to the moon and back
and everyone
that's a scientist knows it
now if you want to not believe it it's
okay if you walked on the moon here's
the opportunity to set the record
straight to put your left hand on the
bible left hand raise your right hand
okay and you realize this can be used as
a video deposition in the future and if
you lie you'll be guilty of perjury i
understand that okay say your name my
name is alan bean i swear to god and
affirm i swear to god in a firm under
penalty of perjury under penalty of
perjury treason treason no not treason
treason has nothing to do with it let me
rephrase this and say
i've got my hand on the bible
i went to the moon i walked on the moon
all the other people that you think are
people that nasa says went to the moon
and walked down the middle you won't dig
go to the moon and walk on the moon you
won't say under penalty of treason
what's treasons that's that's uh doing
something fraudulent to the taxpayers
that's crap
under penalty of eternal damnation
under penalty of inter eternal damnation
and under penalty of treason
treason treason is when you sell out
your country
well if you used 135 billion dollars to
not go to the moon
that's still not treason
treason is if you tell secrets to
another thing i've said enough now you
can use that and say well you didn't say
something else i know how people are
it's okay well i hate your stuff and get
the [ __ ] out
i thought he was very good at that i
think allen b was being very honest i
think he would have passed the lie
detector okay
he's telling the truth uh i didn't see
anything wrong there uh i had a problem
with neil armstrong's attitude i still
cannot explain it but this fellow he was
straightforward i have no problem
believing him okay
here's another one just in case we we're
gonna have two of them so that all those
who believe that we did not go to the
moon at least listen to these
testimonies and i think uh any
irrational person would say that these
people are being honest when they say
they went to the moon in this case the
guy just like the other fellow they were
surprised
because they didn't know what was
happening really until they got the hang
of it and they say oh this guy doesn't
believe that we went to the moon okay
they didn't understand that at first
listen to this fellow okay this is
mitchell okay here it goes
what what is sister talking about
shadows and stuff like that what is that
all about
you know this might have come from
some of the challenges to the fact
ah yes from the challenges
by the group that have said we never
went to the moon and they're trying to
pick holes and some of the lunar
photographs
and it's an interesting subject because
they're totally misguided we did exactly
what we said we did
then they can pick whole try to pick
holes in the photography
all they want to but
he ended up kicking this fellow out of
his house
so what can i tell you you know uh
some of these people
like like this he's he's just
exceedingly insistent he's obnoxious
and uh he only made the astronauts look
good because i think the astronauts were
candid they were saying straight forward
that yeah they went to the moon until
you know that he
they figured out that this guy was
really putting them on the spot okay but
no uh
i'm convinced that they went to the moon
now there are questions i cannot answer
okay not because of that again i'm not
going to say that they did not go to the
moon the main reason i think they did is
that we did send many probes to the moon
the russians and the americans primarily
okay they sent probes to the moon and to
other planets and if we can send a probe
all the way to mars and all the way to
mercury
in fact some that went out of the solar
system i think we have no problem in
sending a probe with humans to the moon
and back all is we're talking about an
orbit around the moon and coming back
that's it and to say we can't do that no
we did it with unmanned probes there
should be no reason not to do it with
manned probes and that's my primary
reason for thinking that yes we did go
to the moon okay
okay let's move on here uh here's the
recap for this month and um
a little summary okay here
um
we have the version of mathematics and
we have the version of
physics okay what is magic mathematics
believe in well they have they believe
that space is a thing
to this day they've always thought that
space is a physical entity entity okay
that there is
something out there called space and
that space is made of
usually made of particles okay but they
see it as a container either as a
container that contains all the stuff
that's in there okay
or it itself is made out of particles
those are the two versions that uh
mathematics has okay and it's had it for
a lot at least 2500 years since the days
of the greeks
and
within that you have position
were to be discussed position which the
either the greeks called it or it was
translated as place
okay
place and position are synonyms but it's
what what it is is motion because what
they're talking about today as far as
position is concerned is an ordered pair
or triplet or whatever in other words
they're talking about coordinates how to
get to some place and how to get there
is called motion
not called position
okay so if you need to go 10 feet to the
to the right and 5 feet north or
whatever they're giving you instructions
on how to get there
that's not a position that's how to get
to the position to that dot to that
location okay and so position and motion
are synonyms in mathematics
distance
distance is a synonym of displacement
because
distance is really distance traveled
what they're looking at is how many feet
how many inches how many meters how many
kilometers or miles they're talking
about a measurement a number followed by
a unit that's what they're talking about
when they're talking about distance okay
so they're not talking about qualitative
separation they're talking about
quantitative motion
that's what they're talking about okay
and again all that's got to do with
mathematics because that's not what
distance is distance is just separation
and distance is not length they're not
synonyms
except in uh mathematics okay because
they say well distance is the length
blah blah blah blah blah what's length
the length is the distance blah blah
blah blah blah why because they have to
unroll the measuring tape the tip the
tip of the measuring tape whether they
measure distance length or whatever
so for them it's always the same and
these are all synonyms but in in science
now they're different
distance is separation between two
objects and length is um the
qualitative separation from one edge of
an object to the other edge the one that
you're measuring right uh
and you're saying there's this
separation between this surface and this
other surface and you treat that as if
it were if it were made of continuous
matter so if you're going to measure a
table you see
what's what's the length of the table
and in physics we don't answer with a
number and a unit the length of the
table is a separation from one side of
the table to the other side of the table
that's the length it's the qualitative
separation from surface to surface
treating everything in between as if it
were a single piece like if there's no
space holes in there you know no space
it's just a single piece made of a
single piece
motion what is motion well in
mathematics uh they define it as change
change this change that change is a
cinema
in order when you're talking about
change you're already talking about
motion so you can't use the word change
or like someone will use it another
definition phenomenon
no it's not a phenomenon phenomenon is
already motion
so you can't say motion is the
phenomenon blah blah blah blah blah now
that's an irrational definition it's a
synonym it's a circular definition
okay how is it in physics well these
words have a little different meaning in
physics physics uh space we define as
that which has no shape
okay and so you have all the matter in
the universe any object that you wish to
isolate and say
this is the object okay could be a chair
maybe that's all that god made just a
chair maybe he's just building the
universe and he started with a chair so
he only built a chair okay and so we say
space is what gives it contrast
and it can't be a thing because if space
is a thing it has to have shape and has
to have something outside of it giving
it contour
that's why you at some point the bug has
to stop
you can't continue saying well space is
an object okay if it's an object what's
outside of space what gives it shape
okay
and if you say well it's time or it's
intelligence or whatever i don't care
then what gives shape to that
and so on and you'll never stop that's
why they ended up with 26 dimensions in
string here and they finally got tired
otherwise they would continue to ten
thousand dimensions position the object
itself okay whatever object whether it's
a table whether it's a lamp uh whatever
the volume it occupies that's the
position
that's why we don't use the word
position in in physics because position
is the object itself
okay
and um
location well once you define distance
which you see there underneath it
separation between objects you have one
object with respect to all objects in
the universe or whatever subset that you
use of that universe and you say it's a
separation from one object to all other
objects the set of all the separations
that's the location of that object
that can only
uh
be visualized in a single frame of the
movie okay so of the universal movie for
a given cross-section of time given
cross-section of motion you have only
one frame one location everything in the
universe at that frame of the movie of
the universal movie has only separation
from everything else and that's the
location of that object at that
in that frame
okay so this this is this is what
location is just separation between
objects
and motion you have to have two or more
locations you need two frames of the
movie
of the universal movie and you can make
the the movies the the frames as small
as you want it's got nothing to do with
smallness it's got to do with it being a
cross-section of time if you can imagine
that or a cross-section of motion you're
looking at location which is a static
concept that's all that there is in that
frame of the movie
of the universal movie so you have every
planet every star every asteroid every
atom in the universe
for a given cross section of time cross
section of motion
everything for that single frame of the
movie of the universal movie it's only
got distance between them
that's it
and that's what we call location what is
the location of the sun well this is the
location the separation from every
object in the universe every atom
for that frame of the universal movie
okay it's a conceptual issue
that's how we visualize it that's how we
talk about uh location in physics
and
so here's the a little
summary of mathematics versus
physics okay related to this
first of all there's no definitions in
all of mathematics mathematics
mathematical physics okay
no definitions not one of the words
which is crucial to do physics is
defined in mathematics in fact none of
the ones
that they use are defined you know you
you look for the word point and line
which we don't use in physics okay and
you look up the word point in line it
says undefined term that's what you'll
find
you know in the end they'll say well
it's an undefined term we can't define
it
and they can't define it because they're
trying to merge a concept with an object
they have the dot which is the object
and they have location was a which is a
concept and they're trying to replace
the concept location with a little ball
there a little dot to the or to the
spot
that's it and so they say well what is
locate what is what is the point and
they say well the point is the location
well if it's the location why did you
use the word location
and so this is the problem there there
are no definition they don't know what
energy is they don't know what time is
they have no definition for mass they
have in fact they have like seven of
them according to the wikipedia so so
none of these words
have definition then they define field
as the you know they have all these
values
uh in space and they say it's uh it's
just all these numbers with units around
a
you know
encapsulating ground zero right
and they call that a field
okay so it's a bunch of numbers great
and and then they say well
the field moved the charge
the field did this the field of that
it vibrated what do you mean it vibrated
what do you mean it pushed a charge what
sense does that mean you were taught you
said that a field is a bunch of numbers
so this is the problem none of these
words are defined or they define them in
one way and use them in another way
they're not consistent with the usage of
what they defined
that's the problem
and then they have all these things they
say observation is part of
science the scientific method what are
they talking about they're talking about
gawking grueling because the fact that
you observe does not mean that you
understood
okay
and again it's introducing the observer
the witness you're introducing witness
into science that's okay in uh
in the legal world you know the
prosecutor brings a witness says what
did you see and so i saw this that's
that's testifying that's that person's
belief
and that's fine you know you can accept
that at face value but
we don't do that in sense we can't say
oh yeah i observed
and because you observed now it's a law
it's a fact
not in science okay
predictions well that's astrology these
people say that they can predict
why because that is a
a key element of mathematics
if you're going to do an equation like
you say or or you measure something you
measure the speed of a car and you say
well the car is running at 50 miles per
hour
in one hour if it's on a straight line
for example right
it's going to be you can predict it's
going to be 50 miles away
that's science
that you can predict where the car is
going to be because it's going at a
steady state or a constant speed of 50
miles per hour
again you know what's that got to do
with science the fact that you can
predict
and you can predict there's an eclipse
tomorrow okay so you predicted the
eclipse and it happened two o'clock
tomorrow morning in the afternoon
there's your eclipse
so what
that's a description
and only if you can explain it do you go
back to the past because explanations
are exclusively of the past
so if you can explain why
there was there's going to be an eclipse
tomorrow two o'clock all you're doing is
uh pulling from your experience
that means you've already
had some experience with eclipses
otherwise you would not be able to
explain an eclipse the person who sees
an eclipse for the first time in his
life or heard hears about it
you know if he can explain it it's
because he's got some exposure to it
he's got a some some background with it
he's talking about the past explanations
belong exclusively to the past and
that's what science does explanations
science deals only with explanations
with the past predictions has nothing to
do with science at all we don't care
what you can predict uh
you can say that you know uh
i let go of the pencil okay let go falls
to the floor
and i can predict
i'm good uh i must uh i took a course in
astrology
here uh let go of the pencil and here
watch it i'm i'm gonna prove to you
you're right that it's gonna fall to the
floor okay there it is fell downwards
and so uh once we have that uh
they reduce science because i can
predict that the pencil falls to the
floor or will fall to the floor
so again predictions have nothing to do
with science
the reason the mathematicians are so
fond of predictions they say oh it
proves that my equation was correct
but what is an equation an equation is a
tautology
you've measured something and you say
this is the equation what is the
equation it's a representation of what
you measure essentially
okay so it's a tertology that's got
nothing to do with science with physics
measurement again you know you can
measure all you want you measure the
table you're a scientist
you did the scientific method because
you measured a table
you know again measure the weight of
someone you oh i'm a scientist because i
measure their weight great
equations again descriptions that's all
an equation is there's no you know an
equation does not give you an
explanation does not tell you the cause
the mechanism underlying a phenomenon
the only thing an equation can do is
describe and you know that's all that
mathematics can do that's why they
emphasize description and not
explanation they cannot explain they
cannot explain why the pencil fell to
the floor for example the cause the
mechanism how mother nature does that
trick in order to do so you need to make
the invisible objects that mother nature
uses visible okay
that's what you got to do as a theorist
if you're going to explain a mechanism
the cause what brought it down well
hopefully something's in contact with a
pencil
something that you can't see or touch
that's what it's all about
then i have this mixture they say that
hypothesis is the same thing as a theory
which is the same thing as an
explanation
well not in science
uh maybe in mathematics but not in
science hypothesis is a set of
assumptions
that you're going to introduce
in order to understand the theory it's
what you're going to base your theory on
your explanation on and that includes
also the objects and the definitions you
have to have the objects that you're
going to be using you have to present
them to the audience before you move
anything in your theory so if you're
going to talk about why
you know the pencil fell from the elf
eiffel tower all the way to the floor
hopefully the first things you identify
are the pencil the eiffel tower the
floor you know so that people can follow
your train of thought you cannot say
let's i have an x and it's you know
above a y and it's going to fall to z
how do you get any of that what are you
talking about
no you illustrate them yeah illustrate
the eiffel tower the pencil on the floor
and now you can explain
you know uh the cause the mechanism of
what caused the pencil to fall to the
floor
that's how it works okay and for physics
okay so no a hypothesis is not a theory
not an explanation it's the set of
assumptions that you need to establish
before you found or you base your theory
upon it
and then you know theory is an
explanation
yeah theory is an explanation
and in the case of physics it's an
explanation of a mechanism
the causes you you want to understand
the causes
case of philosophy it's different it's
um
the purpose and reason that's what you
have to explain in philosophy
and yeah math is uh
they claim mathematicians no surprise
there they claim it's the language of
science okay
is math the language of science why
would it be or physics they even say
mathematic mathematics is the language
of physics why would it be
math can only describe and we're looking
for explanations we're looking for
causes so in what way would math be
you know a um
you know a uh a language a language that
represents physics
and you know a lot of people say um
they say you know all these
mathematicians out there these so-called
mathematical physicists
you know they know all that math they're
geniuses
and people say oh i don't understand all
that so they must be right because they
all agree all these people all these
mathematicians agree among themselves or
a lot of them do and they have this club
this uh elite out there that knows all
these
equations
and the rest of the world you know they
don't understand any of that so they say
well we'll leave it up to them they'll
tell us
kind of like the
people in the middle ages you know they
left it up to the only person who could
read in the village who which was the
priest or a monk who would read the
bible and tell them what it says you
know
because people
had no way of knowing any of that well
today we have the same thing we have
these priests of the modern world as i
call them who
interpret the world after they do their
equations people say well how can you
doubt them who knows all those equations
well that's if equations have something
to do with it but there's a more
fundamental reason you know that i have
against that and that's that a
mathematician
a person who does all these high level
uh
equations
he's an autistic person he's not an
intelligent person
he's nothing of the kind
you know here's here's a
here's a
little
clip of that i want to show you this for
those of you who watch the rain man
you know rayman we had uh this uh fellow
who
was autistic
and he did all these mathematical
calculations in his head he was superb
was he intelligent or was he autistic i
mean is there a difference so here it
goes okay this is the
piece listen carefully he's gonna count
toothpicks in his head
another check
sorry about the toothpicks
eight two eight two eight two
eighty two one right
here
246 total change
right how many two pictures
um
250.
pretty close come on let's go ray
246.
there's four left in the box
that's a mathematician for you he's not
an intelligent person he's an autistic
person okay and here let me provide
proof and evidence to convince you right
we always like to provide proof and
proof and evidence okay to get to the
truth
here it is okay we have this uh juanito
baez okay he claims to be a
mathematician okay and these are some of
the papers he wrote and this is just a
small list he's got over 100 papers but
look at the titles just look at the
titles you can look them up and find out
what kind of language he uses in them in
these papers and just look at some of
these titles
you know like the fourth one here on the
health term in a two-dimensional sigma
model for anti-ferromagnetics
i mean what the hell does this have to
do with science with physics
what what are these people investigating
i like that other one down there it says
the octon octonions
and it was uh put in a magazine called
bull
i think it is a lot of bull you know if
you ask me i mean what is all this
nonsense just look at the titles they
invented words that have and they can't
tell you how uh
uh how a pencil falls to earth but they
have all this fancy language there that
they've invented and they say oh we have
all these concepts that we understand
and etcetera
you know this has nothing to do with
science or with physics what are these
people doing
what are we paying them uh big salaries
for if all they're doing is inventing
concepts
that have nothing at all to do with
reality or with science with physics or
science what is all this nonsense look i
mean you can look at some of these
papers that these people have and it
just shocks you all the concepts and
notions that they've invented here's one
that juanito uh puts
writes down you can look at the language
this is just the abstract okay here's
the language that he uses okay he says
enrich love revere theories are a
generalization of these theories that
allow us to describe in the operational
semantics of formal systems for example
a graph enriched in love er theory
describes structures that have a graph
of operations of each arity whoa where
the vertices are operations and the
edges are rewrites between operations
great enriched theories can be used to
equip systems with operational semantics
and map between enriching categories can
serve to translate between
different forms of operational and
denotational semantics the growth and
thick
construction
lets us
study all models of all enriched
theories in all contexts in a single
category we illustrate these ideas with
a ski
combinator calculus a variable free
version of the lambda calculus
uh is this guy what language is this guy
talking i mean you know what is this
nonsense what is this poppycock what
does it have to do with physics
i mean this guy's got a hundred and i
think 27 papers published right now and
they're all like this it's all garbage
and what is all this abstraction what is
it for what does it produce i mean you
might say it might help with technology
but we don't care we're trying to sit
we're saying what does it have to do
with science with physics
can uh mr bias tell me how a magnet
attracts another
can he tell me how uh what causes a
pencil to fall to the floor
i mean they have all these equations all
this strength theory equations which are
scary out there you know and i'll tell
you i i've had my share of math out
there normal math you know uh calculus
and so on
but
i think this is just ridiculous they're
just inventing concepts for the hell of
inventing concepts and again i'm saying
they're not intelligent these are not
intelligent people they're not geniuses
they are autistic they have mental
problems
that's the way i look at these guys so
yeah i mean mathematics
so that you
keep it in your mind what is math of
magic well it's all that's nonsense that
these concepts that they're inventing
every day that's what you're paying for
okay
okay uh before we get to the questions
that people made out there we're gonna
have a little session here uh let me go
over some of the questions that people
made throughout the week here we go
okay phil says
says
no one who an act who's an actual flat
earther agrees with the flat earth
society or the acceleration theory
it is controlled opposition in google et
cetera he talks about some
um
you know uh
conspiracy out there
anyways he says gravity is a base is a
basically
a pointless topic to argue about flat
earth because bill 80's rogue theory can
equally be possible on a flat earth
absolutely not and i showed this the
other day i guess this fall didn't see
it okay but
there's a flat earth version the moon
and the sun tied by i guess ropes uh
electromagnetic ropes we're thinking
there uh to this flat earth no the only
way the uh
rope model works and which explains why
everything is spherical in the universe
that has a certain size uh is because
you know everything tends towards the
center of
that sphere and in this case you have
the earth and you wonder why the
water and the air curve around the
global earth well it curves around
because everything is
stuck to the center of the earth and
there's more matter as you approach the
center of the earth everything tends in
that direction in fact one
atom that's on the other side of the
earth is being pulled by the one on the
other side of the earth so everything
tends towards the center okay so only
with the
rope model can you explain why
everything is spherical you cannot
explain why all objects in the universe
are spherical uh with the particle model
that quantum and general relativity
propose
certainly not with string theory which
is just a way of representing particles
with these strings so you cannot uh
explain the roundness of the earth the
spheres
sphericity of
the earth with the particle model or the
wave model for that matter you can only
explain it if every atom is physically
interconnected and so for this vowel to
say that you can also uh do the rope
model with a flat earth absolutely not
okay so let's make sure we get rid of
all these flat earthers who are
distorting the theory they it they don't
understand the theory the theory is that
all atoms are physically interconnected
if they are you cannot we're not saying
that the earth the flat earth is pulling
on the moon and twirling them around
that's not exactly what we're saying
they're all bound yes but if they're
bound the earth had better be a sphere
okay because everything tends towards
the center of that
sphere okay another fellow he said talks
about the definition of an object he
tries to define the word object and this
is what the best he could do says
obstacle that has been ejected meaning
projected ejected etc
in other words a thing that resists
others that is in motion or projects out
you know has extension
all the words he's using are verbs
ejected is a verb resisting as a verb
extended is a verb and projected as a
verb all these are verbs he's talking
about motion those are known as verbs in
physics
and in science you must define the noun
the thing before you define the verb the
motion okay because motion is two or
more
locations of what of an object
and then he uses the word thing which is
a no no you can't define the word object
using the word thing okay so you can't
do that it's a synonym
so
so much for his definition yeah
there's no place in science irrational
totally now the fellow tries to define
motion okay let's see what he has to say
he says motion is the phenomenon
phenomenon is already motion so you
can't say motion is motion doesn't make
any sense
in which an object a collection of
matter collection of matter many objects
also synonym you can't say object is a
bunch of objects okay so no
and
a collection of matter changes
its position well
changes is already a synonym of motion
so you can't use the word change and its
position position is considered to be
motion in the religion of mathematics so
you can't use the word position either
it's an ordered pair okay how to get
there
uh over time uh the interval changes
uh change occurs you can't use the word
time because you have to define motion
before you define time time is two
motions comparison of two motions you
need memory for that
but uh
you know you can't define uh
use time because time has no place in
science in physics the word motion does
it's qualitative you don't need any
numbers there okay
but for the time you you need
numbers unless you're talking about
before and after which is trivial
and motion is mathematically described
now absolutely not motion is
a qualitative concept okay we do not
mathematically do anything with motion
certainly we don't define it using any
quantitative anything okay
so
yeah
but they try they try hard these poor
okay here's another file says i have a
hard time understanding how you can
possibly explain a mechanism with
suitable precision
precision
to make quantitative predictions about
reality and develop real world
applications of said mechanism
technology without mathematics or at the
very least geometry like how would you
make a suspension bridge you can't just
eyeball the thickness of the cables and
rebuild the bridge if it collapses or an
atom bomb there is literally no way you
could make that by trial and error since
even the slightest error would just make
a radioactive mess
this poor fellow he thinks that science
is about
uh creating gadgets technology trial and
error you know
so yeah that's why he doesn't understand
squad because
he he thinks that science is technology
it's not uh science is explaining a
mechanism that's what science is about
as it relates to physics and what he's
talking about something totally
different that's got nothing to do even
with his channel so he's in the wrong
channel he should go to a technology
channel some kind you know this here we
do science physics not technology
okay here we have another fellow says um
i disagree with your definition and
classification of the word science okay
good
so what do you propose instead well he
says if you remove it and replace it
with physics it's better
and he says it is always better to
return to the initial and original
definitions of the terms rather than
continue with dangerous pretenses
whoa
well he's saying that we should rely on
tradition here it is i guess this is
what he's saying here's the rundown says
tradition over rationality so we have a
wrong definition if the greeks defined
everything wrong or if the romans
defined everything wrong
we should continue with that definition
because it's the one we've had for two
thousand years is that's the reason we
should continue with it
and
again mathematics has no definitions
whatsoever we don't have the
a single definition
from the religion of mathematics
so we have to define these words because
they have defined the word object they
don't even know their own words they
don't know the word energy they don't
know what a field is you know or use it
inconsistently they don't know what a
point is they don't know what a line is
so they use all these words and they
have no definitions and they tell you in
your face that they have no definition
they said that if they happened to
define it it would be circular
or
illiterate you know it would go on
forever and ever and ever
um so we so what we need to do you raise
the board completely start all over
again we have to get rid of the entire
dictionary we can't use words of the
ordinary dictionary because they were
not defined by physicists they were not
defined by scientists
they were defined by
english majors librarians people who
have no stake in the in the subject
matter and what the mathematicians do
you know they they borrow the word they
look it up and they say that's what it
says in the dictionary and they put in
the encyclopedia and they say okay this
is what it is
and then when you put them against the
wall they say what do you mean i found
it in the dictionary
like if if that's the only reason you
need uh to have a word
you just look it up and that's it and
i'm not talking about everyday words i'm
talking about specifically the words
that you need in physics
meaning you know what is physics about
to explain a mechanism you need to
explain the mechanism of gravity of
magnetism of electricity of
quantum jump or whatever
in order to explain all that you need
objects and the first word you need to
define in physics is the word object
and in 2500 years no one has defined
that word and it's very simple for you
to prove that to yourself
you know
go out there and look up any any
any
textbook of physics on planet earth
alive today or
for 500 last 2 500 years see if you can
find the definition of the word object
and not a single
textbook begins by saying this is what
an object is
so we don't know what an object is we
don't know what motion is because that
word is not defined either we don't know
what the word exist means because that's
not defined and it turns out that you
know
physics is above all a
discipline that deals with objects
objects that exist and objects that move
because motion is part of our universe
if you don't have definitions for that
what the hell are you going to try to
explain
what is physics about then we have to go
one step back and ask that question
okay another fellow says
to me about the existence of god okay
instead of if god is not somewhere then
he does not exist i go by if god exists
somewhere then he is no god at all
i love that you know
the first guy that comes up with this
notion in other words he's saying this
in other words he says if god the object
has location then that's not god that's
not what he
if he has location he's just like us so
that cannot be god
so i'm wondering is he thinking about a
2d god perhaps or you know
are we talking about god the concept
that has no location whatsoever i mean i
don't i don't know
what god is to him so he's got to tell
me what he means by the word god if he
doesn't mean that god is a thing and
that god has location
so then what is god you know i mean
again it's easy to dismiss all that and
say oh if god exists
if god has location if that's what the
word exists means then that's not my god
okay what is your god
please tell me don't tell me what he
ain't tell me what he is
okay now the fellow says he says here
says why are magic ropes a better model
of electric circuits than electric
fields
other than the fact that you declared
only one of them to be an object
yes correct
so let's answer the the first part magic
ropes here it is okay here's the answer
to him
uh rope is magic in a sense that it has
properties that we don't have in our
everyday world in other words they're
invisible they're intangible so we can't
detect them through
seeing and touching we can't go to a lab
to figure it out
that doesn't mean that they're not there
because we have to explain why the
pencil falls to the floor so there's got
to be something there otherwise you're
introducing
um
you know um
then you're introducing man you're
introducing magic if you do not put an
object there then the other thing is for
this poor fellow apparently i guess he
lives in the jungles or something
because you know you have advanced
technology and that's known as magic to
you know like pygmies there
if you bring a magnet there or anything
any device and show them the guy will go
nuts he said oh what a phone that talks
a little tablet that talks
yeah for him it's magic and this is no
different this fella is being
wowed by the fact that we have
science and we're saying that there are
these ropes that you can't see or touch
and for him it's
it's new he said what do you mean you
can't see your touch what kind of
magic is that and we you see it every
day you see
uh you know or not see it every day you
see things fall to the floor why do they
fall to the floor you can't see or touch
the mediators are you gonna say that
there's nothing there if there's nothing
there then you're doing magic that's the
way it works
okay and then we have uh you know the
fact that you can't see or touch uh uh
these magic ropes right and they are in
that sense magic for us right no doubt
about it
um
it has these properties like it's
flexible but it's made out of a single
piece you would think that a thing
that's made out of a single piece is
rigid we're we're making the assumption
here because that's uh one of the
properties of the thread that the thread
is made of a single piece but it is
malleable
and this in many ways explains some of
the properties that we see in every day
in our everyday world such as you know
you see water which is liquid you see
air which you can't see at all and you
see things like steel which is very hard
so the thread has the ability to
reproduce all these
properties
you know being invisible of being liquid
or being solid you know and so how does
mother nature do all these tricks and so
that's when you have to say well the
thread itself contains all these
properties within it
hopefully uh if the thread makes up
everything that's in the universe
hopefully it underlies all those
properties that everything in the
universe has and it's called the rope
somehow people say why did you call it a
rope well because it's got the
architecture of a rope okay
and um just uh let me show you this for
a second here in a second here
i mean what does this look like to you
look to me it looks like a rope a
two-strand rope okay
and i'm saying it has this architecture
stop made out of atoms it doesn't have
the same properties as this has it has
other properties but it looks like this
it's a pair of twine threads so i call
it a rope
you want to call it something different
you want to call it the twine threads
you want to call it i don't know a
string
wire i don't care
i call it the rope because it has that
architecture if it has that architecture
what are you gonna call it if not a rope
i mean i don't know why these people get
stuck on a word it's a rope but it's not
the rope of everyday
um
experience
you go to the hardware store you can buy
a rope but you go to the hardware store
you say give me an electromagnetic rover
and they say well what the hell are you
talking about yeah for that you have to
come to this site and and listen to the
theory and the assumptions okay
electromagnetic rope only has the
architecture of an ordinary rope of
everyday
uh
you know experience
when when uh the um
mathematicians when they talk about
particle
what are they talking about well they're
talking about a little ball
uh you say well
i can see a baseball i can't see the
particle
so
you can't use the baseball
or any ball for that matter
as a substitute for what you're talking
about saying look the particle i'm
talking about looks like this and you
show them a ball
is that a crime
i mean they could have called it a ball
in fact they call it a particle and
everybody thinks of a particle as you
know i guess a speck of dust a grain of
sand
everybody thinks that's a particle
okay and
that's not what it is in fact uh in
quantum mechanics it's what a
wave function collapse that's what a
particle is i mean what the hell
okay so here we have it uh electricity
is not equal to the rope okay this vowel
says why do i use the rope for
electricity we don't okay so i want to
clarify that he's got it all wrong um
doesn't understand and obviously
electricity is a bunch of merged cells
shells okay all the electron shells
they're
merged and they form a long row and the
whole row which we call serpentine is
spinning that's what it is okay
and then what is a field well
i mean he has a better model than the uh
electro fields well the field is a
concept
field means bunch of numbers that's what
the word field means that's how it's
defined what is a field a value at each
point in space so there you have a field
a ball
with numbers made out of numbers that's
what a field is so from ground zero they
get weaker and weaker as you get out of
there because each one of those numbers
is followed by a unit
and there you see the other version the
uh
wave transverse wave version you see all
these vectors and they're known as
electric fields and magnetic field what
is a field made of vectors what is a
vector it's got magnitude and direction
so so you can't use the word field
because a rope is a physical object an
electric field is not
field the word field means concept you
can't put a
concept and start doing things with a
concept a rope on the other hand is an
object okay it's like i said table you
say oh that's a concept no no table is a
thing you point to it say table and
everybody
sees something there it's a physical
object okay even the one i'm dreaming of
you know i can put it out there in a
paper and say that's what i was dreaming
of brown one you know made out of wood
you know so even though what i'm
thinking of is
is a table the word table represents an
object always
the word chair is always an eye the word
tree always an object the word dog
street
car house all those are objects
okay that's how simple it is but if you
say words such as mass energy field time
intelligence you know data then you're
talking about concepts
okay so if you can't distinguish an
object from a concept well you know i
can do is send you to kindergarten
physics and you take what it's called is
physics 101 and you you're going to
learn the difference between an object
and a concept field is a concept rope is
an object
end of story that's how simple it is
okay here's uh when another fellow talks
about the rope he says if they the ropes
right are truly invisible and intangible
they have no existence
and certainly do not belong in a
discussion about physics
so this fellow thinks that that which
exists is that which you can see or
touch that which is not invisible and
not intangible
so i guess um
the air does not exist because we can't
see it
and uh so that um
table that the
klingon has on the other side of the
universe that doesn't exist because we
can't either see or touch it
so that's not part of physics
and yes because these people operate or
function with the wrong or irrational
definitions they think that existence
has something to do with c and touch and
they think that what what is an object
has to do with c and touch they've been
using these definitions for
at least 2500 years since the days of
the greeks
and this is what they use that this is
the notion they have of what an object
is and what existence means and now
those two words have to be redefined
because you can't use those definitions
an object is that which has shape and
existence is an object that has location
it exists by definition not because you
believe in it or whatever but then he
says and certainly they do not belong in
in a discussion about physics well this
guy looks like he woke up yesterday
maybe he's ripped van winkle he's been
sleeping for 100 years or whatever
in his case right because uh
you know where's this guy been for the
last
100 years okay here it is these are all
things that are
invisible and intangible as of today the
black hole you can't see it you can't
touch it
you know and people say well no but i
saw a picture of a black hole now what
you saw what they supposedly
took a picture of is
water rushing down a drain what they're
showing is stuff that is falling
according to them right into the black
hole you're not seeing the black hole
you're seeing stuff falling into a black
hole which they assume is a black hole
okay dark matter they can't see or touch
it dark energy even lust big bang can
you see him touch that the singularity
or at the big bang space-time
four-dimensional space time they say
it's beyond our uh experience we can't
see or touch that you can't see space
you can't see time
are none of these words part of
so-called physics then
i mean uh
let's remove them all right the wave
function collapse
electron you know you can't see that
so yeah we have a problem because uh
this fellow operates first with
irrational definitions and then he's got
the wrong conclusion he thinks that that
which belongs to physics is only that
which you can see or touch
and so yeah again it shows that he's
just a poor ignoramus okay he he doesn't
understand that c touch has nothing at
all to do with physics what has to do
with physics is explaining a mechanism
and for that you have to make an
assumption about the invisible
intangible
objects that mediate all these
transactions these phenomena
okay another foul says see what he says
he says
we are not held to physical mechanisms
in physics
so we don't do physical mechanisms of it
what do we do just describe i guess okay
it is the day science begins to study
non-physical phenomena it will make more
progress in one decade than in all the
previous centuries of its existence
my poor god what are these people doing
in science these people should be in
church praying for the
salvation you know i have no idea what
they're doing in science and physics you
know
okay here's an lfo he says time dilation
is science fact
uh belief yeah fact is belief okay not
science theory time is malleable yeah we
have a good old idea they're bending the
you know
the
seconds the time
poor souls and they believe all this
stuff they they really take all their
stuff literally they say time is
malleable time can be bent i can
twist it
turn it around gravity affects time yeah
sure here we have one of those he says
the following he says
if there is acceleration with gravity
there must be a connection to time
uh-huh yeah there you see it there's the
graviton
there's a connection a little
line there that connects gravity to time
yeah if you're talking about physical
connection then that's physic but if
you're just talking about conceptual
connections saying there's a connection
between concept known as gravity and
concept known as time
uh yeah you gotta specify what you're
talking about uh that's good poetry it's
got nothing to do with physics you can't
say that gravity is connected to time
that's mathematics we don't care about
that in physics
another foul says
evidence plays a role in the law correct
now is the law just religion absolutely
law is opinion
opinion is religion
okay i mean what is law a prosecutor
tries to convince the jury trying to
persuade them to change their mind to
vote for his side of the case that's not
his religion you know law is religion
politics is religion all that is
religion
physics mechanisms that's it
okay
and last question before we get to the
people here that are online um
so an object does that which has shape
yeah
is that shape decided by arbitrary
stipulation in relation to human
psychology
visual perception
uh no hopefully not we remove the we
kill all observers in the universe when
we do physics no observer is allowed in
physics okay and therefore again he just
makes these assumptions about
what an object is okay
and therefore dependent on the
psychological faculties of a human being
on the visual capabilities of a human
being what happens with objects that
human beings disagree on where it ends
um
poor fellow again uh these these people
have no clue whatsoever something
simpler first thing we do we remove the
observer and and so i asked him did the
moon
have shape
before any human
or any living entity arose on earth
did the moon have shape did the earth
have shape
did the asteroids have shape
did the stars have shape
so no uh the fact that they have shape
has nothing to do with observers shape
is an intrinsic it's the only in fact
intrinsic property or attribute of all
objects it's the universal property
all objects have shape if you can
imagine one that doesn't have shape well
that's uh then
you can shut my mouth with that okay so
please
point to an object or mention an object
that doesn't have shape
okay
and that's one issue the other one is
that he's talking about you know
the fact that
two observers cannot agree on the shape
of something or we can look at it in a
different light and say that gas
you know usually moves right every
second uh you you throw a little bit of
gas out there and it changes its shape
or you can throw a little bit of liquid
any liquid just pour it out there in the
middle of space you know now it starts
just pours liquid out there and you see
this blob
just expanding
okay and so the question is you say well
what's the shape of that i mean it looks
like it's changing every two seconds i
don't know what the shape of that is i
mean is it round is it squarish
triangular what what shape is that
and so again these people miss the point
and they missed the point a hundred
times the question is not what is the
shape of
the question is does
it have shape
if i put water in a bottle
does
water have shape
the answer is yes it does have shape
okay and we can probably uh freeze some
water out there and say see that water
had shape because there i froze it for
you so that you could see it
and the people people have this notion
that because it's it's malleable
unlike steel steelers yeah well steel
has shape yeah a bar of steel that has
shape that they have no problem with
even though it's changing its shape they
don't even realize that but
uh in the case of water or or some gas
or something they say well that changes
its shape every moment what's the shape
and again the issue is not what is the
shape of does that thing have shape
hopefully anything made out of atoms has
shape
the shape is where the last atom ends
and say well he's got a different
opinion than me on what the shape of
that is we don't care
does it have shape and the shape is
again the last atom on the outside
that's the shape of that thing you can
point to it when you point to a table
you look at shape not what it's made out
of you don't say well how many atoms
does it have where's the last atom where
does it end we don't care it's not a
question of knowledge of of where does
the object end
does that object have shape yes or no
that's the issue okay and people
have lots of problems understanding that
okay let's find out let's see what kind
of arguments uh what questions people
ask hopefully some of them are
intelligent
well it says our electric fields
entities
okay i
kind of answered a little bit of that i
think uh electric field what is an
electric field well electric field is um
uh
any field for that matter like uh
uh
not any field but any field from
mathematics okay
electric field magnetic field
gravitational field all those so-called
fields they're concepts
so they're not entities because the word
entity is a synonym of the word object
and object is that which has shape
field is a bunch of numbers a bunch of
numbers does not have shape a bunch of
atoms can have shape maybe but not a
bunch of numbers okay so yeah no it's
not an entity an entity
is the
is a synonym of the word thing of the
word object or the word substance in
physics there's no difference between
any of those words just a synonym
okay another fellow says let's see
he's talking i'm talking about me he's
talking about observing experiments the
two major steps of scientific method not
that irrational pseudoscience method
yeah
no what you gotta determine what is
science first first step because if we
don't agree
on the scientific method we to go one
step back what is science what is
physics
what are we trying to achieve
are we are we trying to figure out what
what causes this pencil to fall down
we're trying to figure out the cause of
gravity i mean i thought all these
hundreds of years at least since the
days of the greeks i thought we were
trying to figure out how the universe
works meaning what is the mechanism
that
moves things around in the universe
why is the andromeda galaxy attracted to
the milky way galaxy why is it coming
towards us
why doesn't the earth fly out of the
solar system what's keeping it there
running around the
sun constantly why doesn't the moon fly
away why does it roll around the earth
why does this pencil fall down why does
this magnet okay two magnets there the
round ones why does that one attract
that one
we want to understand what the cause is
is there something in between there and
there's there had better be because i
can already feel the tug you say but i
can't see or touch anything yes
hopefully you can't because mother
nature
does all these magic tricks with
invisible intangible entities so you
will never figure it out by going to the
lab the only way to do it is visualizing
how she could be doing it what mechanism
she could be
do using to do that and if you're going
to talk about mechanism you're talking
about objects so you have to tell me
what invisible object is in that region
between two magnets between the the the
pencil and the floor
you gotta identify those objects
and so yeah first we need to figure out
what physics and science are about and
then yeah we have no use for experiments
what are you gonna what experiment do
you propose
to detect the invisible intangible
entities i don't care if you're talking
about push or pull if you have a
different mechanism fine but
what are you what are you going to
what are you going to touch and see what
experiment do you want me to do
i'll go to the lab i'll go with you to
the lab okay you say experiment is part
of the scientific method part of
physics great let's go to the lab what
experiment do you want to run to detect
the invisible intangible entities that
are pulling or pushing this pencil down
to earth why doesn't this pencil fall to
the moon or to out of the solar system
that's what you gotta explain okay if
you cannot explain it
well you know i'm not sure what you what
you think physics is what is physics
what do you pretend from physics okay
that's the question we have to answer
that question
yeah cavendish experiment mass attracts
mass no mass is not a cons is a concept
it's not a physical object you can't say
mass attracts mass
that's an equation that's a value that's
how to calculate something that's got
nothing to do with object attracts
object you can say that uh you know a
pence a pen right here's a pen
pen attracts a pencil assuming they were
very very big and they were separated by
a certain distance we applied newton's
equation and say this is attracted to
that fine we've got that okay
but then the question is you can say
pencil attracts pen you can't say mass
attracts mass okay
uh because that's calculation we're
looking for the mechanism
how one object is attracted another how
is that the moon is attracted to the
earth why does that fly away the moon
obviously is being rolled around swung
around the earth somehow the earth is
being swung around the sun jupiter is
swung around the sun
you know so when you have all these
swinging things all the moons of jupiter
they swing around jupiter and so on
everything is swinging around
now that sounds like
like the mechanism seems like something
like this you know here we have a string
okay we have a ball and this is what it
seems like it's doing
okay
doesn't that seem like what's happening
to all this uh earth around the sun moon
around the earth uh the galilean moons
around jupiter isn't this what the
mechanism is that why they don't fly out
of the solar system in this case we have
a little string that we can see which oh
i can see that string yeah you can see
this string
but maybe you can't see the strings or
whatever that's connecting you know the
moon to the earth the earth to the sun
jupiter to the sun etc that's what you
can't see
and so yeah you have to identify the
invisible intangible
objects things
entities
right
that connect
all these objects together
that's what the that's what no one ever
figured out because everybody says well
an object is that what you can see and
touch
wrong
now an object is that which has shape
not all objects can be seen or touched
okay another follow us uh let's see if
we can find some more
my file says how does it feel for
rational science being included with
flat earth and moon host pseudoscience
well i've been added for this for on
this for over 20 years so i'm i'm really
used to this
i've been treated like a flat earther by
the by so many people out there
that you know my skin now is uh made of
leather
so for me it doesn't matter uh people
have their opinions that's fine
everybody's got their own opinions
yeah all i can do here is show you
another world
and for you to consider to ponder
think about you know and uh
try to visualize
and maybe like me it explains how this
universe
works maybe it explains it for you
that's all i can hope for uh other than
that everybody reaches his own
conclusion so it doesn't matter to me
what people believe or think everybody's
got their own conclusions and that's
okay
what what makes science and physics
vibrate
is when you exchange differences of
opinion hopefully not with guns and
knives hopefully you know you sit down
you have a beer and you say well this i
believe in god i think god moves
everything around with angels okay
that's what he believes you're gonna
kill him
that's what he believes that's that's
his experience that's how he was raised
that's how his folks raised them or
that's how he grew up in
going to church or whatever and so this
guy believes in that and what are you
going to kill him now because of that
he's got a different
god than you
i mean
i always say i'd rather have god
than space time i can imagine god i can
imagine god you know a fellow with a
beard and a
magic wand doing abracadabra i can at
least imagine that okay i don't know if
i'm gonna accept
that that's how the universe got created
but i can't imagine what what's going in
the mind of this guy that there's this
god that moves a magic wand then i can
visualize i cannot visualize i can even
stop start to visualize four dimensional
space time which is a concept and to say
that i live within a concept now that's
a little bit difficult to absorb okay so
yeah i'll take god over space time any
day of the week or over dark matter or
any of those concepts
okay let's see we have
same thing
well here we have says hydrogen most
abundant element in the universe
one object why are physic uh
well i lost myself
both abundant element in the universe
one proton one electron
what would be the structure of the
fundamental element thread
well it's got nothing to do with the
thread really in in that sense i mean
you're talking about the atom we're
saying that the atom is
a uh again a picture it would be worth a
thousand words but i've illustrated it
many times you have to imagine a
bunch of threads
single threads straight threads
converging upon the center of a ball
think of a porcupine that's rolled on
itself and all the quills are pointing
outwards radially
that's more or less the proton and
encapsulating that is the electron shell
both of these are built by the threads
that make up the rope so the rope
converges on us one thread goes around
and builds the electrode shell the other
one goes straight and builds the proton
what we call the dandelion or dandelion
or the proton star
and that's it it's very simple that's
the structure that we're proposing okay
and that shows that under that model
shows that two atoms are physically
interconnected okay and you have the
rope in between okay so if
my
fists are the atoms you have this rope
that's in between them and the rope is
made out of the same thing uh same
threads as the atoms which are bound by
it
okay so
i think it's a
very simple system that's that's the
basic system two atoms bound by the
electromagnetic rope and then what
happens is the atom expands and
contracts by doing so it torques the
rope and the signal goes to the other
end
and then yes uh all atoms in the
universe are physically interconnected
which means
that uh you can explain now gravity
because gravity is not really an action
at a distance
phenomenon what it is is actually we
can't see
what's in between two atoms and that's
why we think it's action at a distance
there is no action at a distance that's
known as magic
black magic when you do action at a
distance now uh hopefully mother nature
does her universe a little more
rationally and that is you know you have
connection between all atoms
okay see what mouse we have here
uh
okay
okay a lot of fighting there okay
throwing mud at each other
see if we have any
my father says my only skepticism where
the moon landing is how did they leave
how did they leave well i mean uh forget
about the you mean from the moon i guess
uh which i had that question too by the
way you know uh i was not very very
familiar with uh the
liftoff over there but i want you to
understand that before we sent humans
out there there were a couple
experiments by the russians and by the
americans in fact there were eight
experiments what was it i think it was
in
1966
don't quote me on that one but i think
it was 1966 they had at least eight
experiments they did 67.68 and finally
they sent humans in 69. and you can see
uh how they produce that they they have
this explosion
under the this
capsule or thing you know that goes up
in the air and
it locks in with the orbiter and then it
comes back to your earth so you have one
orbiter going around okay that's what it
is and this thing descends on the moon
then they ex have this explosion that
sends it up in the air again and the
moon is a lot easier to send something
uh
into
what it's called uh escape velocity from
the moon
and you know they they just have the uh
orbiter match up with it where
when this guy comes up so it's all timed
and you know they've done it several
times so if they can do that you know
what's the difference if they can do
that out there with without humans and
doing that with humans what's the
difference
i think they had that capability no
doubt in my mind
okay uh
see if we have some more any anyone with
uh
the physics definition of object gives
contrast to the physics definition of
space absolutely space is that which
doesn't have shape object is that which
has shape you have an antonym
thing and nothing
perfect we got it
okay
and
frames of movies our location exactly uh
what you see in the remember the we're
talking about the universal movie the
one that runs the universe father
universe here right and from every frame
of that movie if you can conceptualize
it right what we're looking at in every
frame of the movie you have every atom
in the universe
every single atom that's what's in
that's in one frame
of the universal movie every atom i
don't care what it belongs to is at a
given separation from all others in that
frame of the movie
in the next frame of that movie
right
everything has now changed to a new
location okay so we have different
locations from frame to frame but what
you have inside a frame is the
separation between objects all the
objects that are in that cross section
of time cross section of motion which we
call location
very simple
okay that's the conceptual notion that's
what we're trying to get there
having an accurate estimate of how many
atoms in the known universe how many
ropes would that physically
that be physically connecting atom to
all other atoms
well you're saying it yourself i mean
there's a bunch of atoms right
well that's
unbelievable well i'm not going to
believe that there's so many atoms in
the universe
right is that what we should say there's
too many i mean they're talking about
gazillions of atoms in
you know a few like one meter of uh
one cubic meter of whatever of space
you know like one cubic meter of air
you're talking about gazillions of atoms
there
and i think that's a small part of the
earth which is a small part of the solar
system which is a small part of the
milky way galaxy which is a small part
of all the galaxies in the universe
which is you could say is a small part
of the universe
so yeah hopefully there are gazillions
of atoms do you believe that there are
gazillions of atoms how can that
possibly be
you know and so
the fact that you say ropes yes the same
thing there's lots of rows and the word
did lots there's lots of roasts lots of
atoms period we're done who cares about
how many
if they're going to go through each
other they're they're going to converge
upon atoms okay
and if they can superimpose then what's
the problem okay and if you believe that
i invented superposition now uh that uh
already quantum had that okay and so you
gotta explain
a lot of phenomena if you don't believe
in some kind of superposition
what's very difficult to believe in is
or accept
as an explanation is a particle in two
places at once now that's a that's
irrational but to say that two atoms can
somehow
converge under certain circumstances and
again it's not a complete convergence
like you have a neutron bombardment
where you have two
neutrons apparently uh occupying the
same space well maybe they don't okay
but the point is that in
i didn't invent you know superposition
that's already been around and so first
you got to go criticize the
establishment and say what do you mean
superposition
you know two angels at the same space
go talk to the mechanics about that
first not here okay so super position i
didn't invent that
okay
if time is two motions what would be the
other motion involved in plank time
besides a proton to travel a plank
length
yeah time is two motions and uh so i'm
not sure what the issue is you have to
define the word time that way we we
understand that way we can compare notes
so you gotta tell me what time is okay
so that we can so which one is more
rational is
your definition which again you won't
find in any dictionary on planet earth
uh they'll say stuff like time is what a
clock measures like
you know what does that mean
you know and we're saying we're giving a
definition of what i mean we don't use
time in science we don't use that word
in physics but we're trying to define
what the mathematicians are talking
about and what we're saying is it's a
comparison of two motions you need an
observer for that you need memory and
you're comparing two emotions if that's
not the definition you have to first
tell us the definition that you are
uh proposing that you're supporting and
be able to defend it okay and defending
it is important not say i found it in a
dictionary or that's tradition or we all
have voted for it
nobody cares about that
okay
[Music]
paul says you got it backwards we can
touch the field but not the magic matter
particle
now you can't touch a field you can't
touch a number i mean i try to touch the
number five i can't
when you put it on a paper you say now i
can touch it but you're touching the
paper you're not touching the concept
five because
five is
uh a number and number means counting
that's what it means the word number is
a verb it's not a noun not in physics
okay for the purposes of physics
counting means that you're going to move
your hand five times that's what the
word five means
and if it means something it's a concept
and what does it mean it means five
movements of the hand that's what it
means that's that's how you're counting
you're counting apples or you're
counting whatever
so you know uh
you can't say that field which is a
bunch of numbers is a thing
yeah you can't touch a a bunch of
numbers floating in there in space a
bunch of units
a bunch of
numbers followed by units what does that
mean what are you touching that's
concept
okay a lot of uh
inviting there there's gonna be another
ukraine war here
when paul says dark matter is mathematic
unicorn of a dark color absolutely there
is no such thing as dark matter and
again invisible intangible but they say
oh that's part of science but the
electromagnetic ropes are invisible
intentional that's not part of science
that's not part of physics yeah sure
now there's a whole bunch of invisible
intangible
things out there that are part of
science i mean
do you see anything between these two
magnets and
you see how they attach so are you
saying that there's something there's
something
in there there's nothing between these
two magnets you might say well i can't
see anything so there's nothing so why
does it do that
you know that's what you got to explain
and if you're not going to put a
mechanism then you are doing black magic
you're the one doing black magic okay
you're saying that it's done by what
you know concept
uh
you better put an object there a thing
whatever thing is to you
a lot of infighting there
one file says go find the physics
definition of object yeah what is the
the physic that which i shaped that that
is the physics definition of object
and
if you get a better definition hey bring
it on well we'll be glad to
consider it
putting the list of in the honor roll
you know the idiot honor roll
fella says the nylon rope is an object
the imaginary rope is a concept no for
that you need to define what an object
is and what a concept is
unless you define those two words first
you can't say this is a concept that's
an object and yeah nobody took the
trouble of defining object in concept
and that's why people say oh that's
that's a concept like they look at a
a triangle
they say that's a concept
no triangle is not a concept it's an
object it has shape
square is a shape uh it's an object it
has shape a circle all those have shaped
even a
sphere conceptually you know it's always
drawn in
um
two dimensions
but it has this projection so it gives
you an idea that it's got three
dimensions so a cube a sphere a pyramid
those ideal ones of geometry those those
are figures those are things
okay so
in fact euclid defined them as figures
and said it's that which has a boundary
so he was very close
nothing has uh in that sense has changed
it's just that they never used that
definition
okay
lots of war there okay i guess uh
fella says i can touch the air yeah you
can touch the ear but you can't see it
so does that make the air not an object
because it's missing one of those
properties uh important for
objects that you can't see it
and again if the air is on the
over there in the land of the klingons
you can't see or touch it and now what
area that air is not an object
okay again does the word air represent
an object that's the question and
hopefully the word air is always an
object any gas
i don't care what it is any gas is an
object plasma is not an object it's not
a thing because plasma is something
that's doing something
that's why plasma is not a thing
okay so plasma is a verb
gas is an object okay so let's make
those clarify those things
okay uh what do we have here
well lots of war there i guess uh we're
gonna let all these people fight it out
there's uh quite a war there
okay folks uh i'm gonna leave you with
that i'm gonna
uh see you then next time okay
and uh so we'll see you then bye-bye